-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for tuning in.
Well, guys, everyone is
talking about this.
One of the biggest
events of the year --
the new Taylor Swift Eras movie
opened today in Los Angeles,
and it premiered to thousands
of fans at a giant mall.
Yeah, that's how
powerful Taylor is.
In 2023, she can get people
to a mall.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Right now, the friendship
bracelet section at Claire's
looks like a Walmart
on Black Friday.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Taylor's movie is expected
to have the biggest opening
ever for a concert film
and could make $200 million.
[ Cheers and applause ]
At this point,
the United States is essentially
a Taylor Swift-based economy.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
But theaters are encouraging
everyone
who goes to the movie to sing,
dance, and take selfies.
It's a real experience.
The movie is so popular,
they're going to have to
start showing it in stadiums,
and it's going to be called
Taylor Swift The Eras Tour
The Movie The Tour.
[ Laughter ]
Well, let's get to some news.
Congressman Jorge Santos
was just hit
with 10 more criminal charges
that accused him of stealing
his donors' identities
and credit cards.
[ Laughter ]
Santos was like, "Wait.
Am I not Henrietta Ellenburg,
from Youngstown, Ohio?"
[ Laughter ]
It's wild.
Santos is either gonna wind up
as Trump's running mate
or Trump's cellmate.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's not looking good
for Santos.
In his defense, his lawyer just
posted the Kevin James meme.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Some more news from Washington.
This morning,
during a closed-door meeting,
Republicans nominated
Steve Scalise
to be the next
speaker of the House.
And during the meeting,
congressmen were encouraged
to sing, dance,
and take selfies.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Steve Scalise
was nominated,
and then Jorge Santos
was like,
"Thank you. I accept.
Thank you."
[ Laughter ]
Well, switching gears,
Amazon Prime Day
started yesterday,
and I read that Amazon
has actually been trying
to crack down
on fake product reviews,
but luckily you can usually
tell when a review is fake.
For instance, here's
a pack of Necco Wafers.
The fake review says...
[ Laughter ]
Can't be real.
The real review says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's terrible.
-See what I'm saying?
You can tell.
[ Applause ]
Next up, here's a little model
BMW toy car.
Fake review says...
The real one says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
7 years old.
Here's a Darth Vader
Echo Dot speaker.
The fake review says...
The real one says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Imitating Darth Vader
breathing ]
-Next up, here's a 14-foot
garage freezer.
Fake reviews says...
Real one says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Two bodies...
Next up,
here's a full body pillow.
-Oh.
-Yeah, the fake review says...
A real one says...
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
Dustin and Susan.
-That's the real review.
-That's the real one.
That's the -- correct.
Yep. Next, here's the 3-in-1
sports center for kids.
Yeah. A fake review says...
Real one says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, here's a
brain-shaped Jell-O mold.
Fake reviews says...
Real one says...
Yeah. See?
Now you can trust the review.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Hey, guys, listen to this.
According to a new report,
NASA believes that, by 2040,
Americans will be living
in houses on the Moon.
-Yeah.
-Nice.
-And you thought it was tough
getting your friends to visit
after you moved
to the suburbs.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we're just two decades
away from an HGTV show
where someone's like, "I love
the schools in this crater,
but I just hate
the kitchen countertops."
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
Today, Birkenstock went public
at a valuation of $8 billion.
-Ooh.
-When they rang the bell
at the New York Stock Exchange,
the bell was like, "Ugh!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
"Need to take a shower,
and then I'll be good."
Actually,
'cause it's Birkenstock,
they didn't ring
the opening bell,
they just drummed
the opening bongo.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this -- the prize
for tonight's Powerball drawing
is over $1.7 billion,
the second-biggest jackpot
in lottery history.
-And I already got my numbers
locked and loaded, Jimmy.
Let's go.
-Oh, really?
I didn't even know you played
Powerball, Kamal.
Good luck.
-First number's 66, man.
That's the date
I met my wife, June 6th.
Boom.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-That's really sweet.
-Next number's 20.
We've been married 20 years.
-20 years.
Congratulations, bud.
Thanks, man. Thanks.
It feels good.
My next number, 24.
That's how many times
my wife told me
not to spend the whole paycheck
on lottery tickets.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, maybe don't spend
the whole paycheck on it.
-And then there's 25.
That's the number of times
I told my wife
we need to win the Powerball
'cause I just bought us a pair
of Jet Skis that I want to ride
at the same time,
like the Little Mermaid's dad
riding a pair of dolphins.
You ever ride a dolphin,
J roll?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I can't say
I ever have.
What's the next number?
-3.
My wife hasn't returned
my texts in three days.
[ Laughter ]
Even when she does, it's usually
something like,
"I guess," or "K."
-That doesn't sound good.
Finally, what's
your Powerball number?
-6. 'Cause I'm staying
at a Motel 6 tonight.
Continental breakfast, baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Unless -- Unless, Jimmy,
still got that
guest bedroom at your place?
I'd love to crash there.
-Kamal Gray, everybody.
Good luck at the Powerball,
Kamal.
I hope you win.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, guys,
I saw that to avoid
repeating last year's holiday
travel meltdown,
Southwest Airlines is stepping
up their preparation
for the winter now.
Yep, they're very prepared.
They've already had
300 texts drafted
that say,
"Your flight is canceled."
All you have to do
is hit send.
Guys, I heard about a dog
in Michigan
that was rescued
after getting his head
stuck in a plastic
cheese-ball container.
Look at this.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
-That will basically be
everyone's pet
when we're living on the Moon.
[ Laughter ]
After getting his head out,
he was like, "Wait. Is that
cheese powder in there?"
and got it stuck in there again.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, it's time for
"Good News, Bad News."
First up, the good news --
"Taylor Swift: The Eras Tour"
hit theaters this weekend.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bad news is, Lauren Boebert
and her date reserved
the seats right next to you.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah.
The good news is,
Biden is trying
to ban hidden junk fees.
The bad news is, you got fired
for Googling
"hidden junk"
on your work computer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's some good news.
Alaska Airlines is making
its own custom-blend coffee.
The bad news,
Spirit Airlines
is continuing to bootleg
its own moonshine.
[ Laughter ]
The good news is,
Chip and Joanna Gaines
are launching a podcast.
The bad news is, if you take
a drink every time
they say "shiplap,"
you'll black out.
[ Laughter ]
Up next, some good news.
California has banned a type
of artificial red dye in food.
-Whoo!
-Yep. Bad news is,
the Kool-Aid Man
was just like, "Oh, nooo!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
The good news is, Panda Express
is now offering dessert.
-Ooh!
[ Scattered cheers ]
-The bad news is, Panda Express
is now offering dessert.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Maybe I should give you
the bad news first, right?
That might be better.
All right, here we go. Yeah.
The bad news is,
Paris is reeling
from a bedbug infestation.
Good news is,
Pixar is making a movie
where a French bedbug
runs a hotel.
[ Laughter ]
I'd watch that.
-Oui, oui!
-[ French accent ]
Welcome to a bed!
[ Normal voice ]
Next, the bad news,
the new iPhone 15
has been overheating.
The good news is that burnt hand
is still better
than green texts
in the group chat.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, the bad news --
edible cookie dough
is being recalled
for containing
an undeclared allergen.
The good news is, warning
about eating raw cookie
dough never stopped you before.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And, finally, the bad news.
Trump and Biden appear to be
heading for a rematch in 2024.
[ Audience groans ]
Good news is, the loser
gets to star in the next season
of "The Golden Bachelor."
There you go.
That would work.
I'll watch that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, finally, everyone's still
talking about Taylor Swift
and Travis Kelce and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Why not?
I know.
We love them both,
but the relationship
has united two groups
that don't normally hang out --
Taylor Swift fans and NFL fans.
Well, we wanted to test
their knowledge of each other,
so we went down
to 30 Rock Plaza
this afternoon
and asked dads
and their daughters
about Taylor and Travis
with one catch -- the daughters
could only answer questions
about Travis,
and the dads could only
answer questions about Taylor.
-♪ "Tonight Show" Swap Quiz,
"Tonight Show" Swap Quiz ♪
-What is the title of
Taylor Swift's first album?
-"Tim McGraw."
-"1985."
-"1989"?
-No!
-"Taylor Swift."
-Yes.
-What team does Travis Kelce
play for?
-Kentucky Chiefs.
-Who is the quarterback
on Travis' team?
-Jonathan Morris.
-Gage Gatlinburg.
-Patrick Mahomes.
-Finish the song title.
"Look What You..."
-"Have Done to Me."
"Recently."
-"Back to..."
-"The Future."
-Daddy!
-What position
does Travis play?
-Tight end.
-What number is Travis Kelce?
-87.
Finish this song title.
"Cruel..."
-"Intentions."
-"Cruel..."
-Finish the lyric.
"'Cause, baby, now we got..."
-"Back from downtown."
-"Each other."
-What is Taylor Swift's
middle name?
-Charlotte.
-I don't know, but I know
that it's not Charlotte.
-Can you sing the song
"You Need to Calm Down"?
♪ You need to calm down ♪
♪ Down, down ♪
[ Laughs ]
-"We are never, ever, ever..."
-"Going to live again."
-[ Laughs ] What?! What?!
Oh! Thank you, everybody,
for playing.